[Music]  Vanessa Hudgens dishes on dropping 30  pounds fast the powerless star opens up  in the May issue of women's health  magazine about the steps she took to get  her sexy physique oh man there's so many  Vanessa secret she credits a strict diet  consisting of high fats and low carbs as  the reason she shed 10 pounds in only a  month a typical meal for the actress  includes eggs and bacon for breakfast a  chicken salad for lunch  grilled salmon and sake with veggies for  dinner  and get this an avocado a day we are  sweating through our clothes day in and  day out as for her intense workout  routine Vanessa says going to SoulCycle  twice a day helps her lose another 20  pounds I'm really competitive when it  comes to fitness I like love SoulCycle I  love Pilates I love yoga love hiking I  love dancing if I can I do it seven days  a week  [Music]  you